Film Courage: Are you a better writer when
you are going through happy times in your
life or when things are a little more uncertain
and that’s when you’re more creative?
Todd Berger, Co-Writer of THE HAPPYTIME MURDERS:
I think you are always kind of the same writer
no matter what mood you’re in.
But what you’re writing about changes.
I think everything we write about says something
about something, right?
Whether it says something about the human
condition or the world.
And if I’m in happier times, if I’m in
better moods, I’m probably writing something
that is more specifically positive or is celebrating
the good things about humanity.
But if I’m in a darker place.
If I’m sad or if I’m upset, I’m probably
writing something that is a biting satire
of the bad parts of the human condition.
But probably the writing level is the same.
I don’t think me being in a bad place or
something makes me a better writer.
And I definitely don’t think artists need
to suffer in order to make good art.
But I think what you are making art about
definitely probably changes and depending
on what you’re experiencing at any given
moment.